des programmes je le combattrai d'avs
toute mon énergie jusqu'au bout c'est
une droite qui n'a aucune générosité qui
n'a aucune humanité a refait une droite
très conservatrices très radicale qui
arrivent au pouvoir
pouvoir n'a rien d'un côté avec une chez
fillon un projet qui est un projet très
européiste très ultralibéral parfait le
projet de la troïka qui a été appliquée
en grèce et dans les pays d'europe du
sud ces dernières années par françois
bayrou qui écrit que le programme de
françois fillon pose de nombreuses
questions qui devront trouver réponses
il pourrait se présenter qu'est-ce que
vous le dites ce matin à françois bayrou
car ça n'est pas comme ça qu'on mène une
politique pour la france
j'invite d'ailleurs françois bayrou s'il
n'est pas à l'aise avec le proche le
projet de françois fillon à nous
rejoindre parce que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de convergences par console
bayrou c'est très bien que la division
pourrait conduire à une situation
dramatique pour les idées qu'on
représente
c'est bernard accoyer qui tient la corde
pour vous succéder ce sera un bon
président du parti madame artichauts je
ne vais pas commenter à votre micro des
rumeurs même si vous les exprimé avec
beaucoup de délicatesse
non je peux absolument pas vous
confirmer ça c'est une information qui
est fausse
d'ailleurs je remarque qu'on parle de la
nomination de bernard accoyer au poste
de secrétaire général oscar général de
public hein c'est pas laurent wauquiez
c'est eric woerth par la droite à son
champion comment va faire la gauche fera
qu'assez pour avoir un chanteur la
primaire
marcel interview du premier ministre
dans le jdd qui a mis le feu aux poudres
manuel valls déclare qu'il n'exclut pas
de se présenter face à françois hollande
à la primaire du ps en janvier
harry comprend très mal ce qui motive
une telle impatience du premier ministre
et s'il souhaite être candidat il ne
peut pas être premier ministre
alors quitte à imaginer que manuel valls
et françois hollande puisse être
ensemble dans la primaire ça n'a pas de
sens qu'à partir du moment où la
primaire a été acceptée par les
socialistes ça peut pas être une petite
primaire un petit coup de claude
bartolone la pression d'après ce que je
dis qu'elle en a gros sur la patate dans
sa langue dans sa relation avec avec
françois blancard si jamais arrivé qu'à
couple exécutif se déchire en direct et
envisage d'être concurrents pour la même
compétition
c'est hallucinant prix n'y aura pas de
primaires entre le président de la
république et le premier ministre
les choses ont été dites et de manière
claire
ça n'existe pas ça ne peut pas
s'imaginer manuel valls eux sourit
françois hollande paraît détendu
ils le raccompagnent après 2h des
changes
les deux hommes ne ferons aucun
commentaire mais dans l'entourage de
françois hollande on évoque une ambiance
tout à fait cordiale et studieuse
[Musique]